et notre invité politique ce matin csn
cias guérini venge bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nos déléguée
générale de la république en marche en
détention pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
julien l'été de la voix du nord bonjour
oriane bon jour et nuit on commence bien
sûr par la crise sanitaire installé
islas green et jean castex qui est
attendu très attendu ce soir à 18 heures
par les français qu'ils se posent de
nombreuses questions sur ce qui va se
passer au delà du 15 décembre
vu les chiffres de contamination qui ne
sont pas fidèles à l'objectif que
s'était fixé
fx et emmanuel macron est-ce qu'on peut
tenir le calendrier fixé par le
président de la république ou est ce que
vous dites il faut renoncer à alléger le
confinement comme prévu pas ce qui est
certain c'est qu'il faut rester
extrêmement prudent
moi ma première remarque c'est que c'est
notre responsabilité collective à tous
et pas seulement le gouvernement ce pas
seulement le premier ministre qui
annonce des choses qui prend une
décision
moi je pense depuis le début de cette
crise qu'on n'est pas des enfants
on a une part de la solution entre nos
mains que par nos actes quotidiens
personnel bah on a une responsabilité et
des conséquences sur ce qui va se passer
pour la suite donc le gouvernement devra
prendre ses responsabilités moi je suis
pas venu vous annoncer quoi que ce soit
j'ai pas les informations de ce qui sera
annoncé tout à l'heure il ya des
discussions qui vont continuer je sais
une chose c'est que depuis le début de
cette crise
on garde une boussole et la boussole
c'est la santé des français mais vous
vous que je vois vous plaidez est ce que
vous pouvez imaginer
peut-être que on puisse finalement son
sont contents se contenter d'une
extension du couvre-feu ou peut-être
faire l'impasse sur sur des déplacements
pour noël je crois vous savez que les
fêtes de noël la soirée de noël
elle doit être préservé il faut veiller
à prendre des mesures qui soient ensuite
appliquées
les français ont envie de pouvoir
retrouver mon petit cercle leurs
familles pour le soir de noël n'en suis
pas tenable interdire l'été place il me
semble que c'est c'est difficile de ne
pas permettre aux uns et aux autres de
ne pas retrouver leur cercle familial
il ya beaucoup d'envié il ya une
situation aussi difficile d'un point de
vue psychologique pour le pays c'est
bien normal
on a tous envie pouvoir retrouver
d'autres familles mais surtout surtout
mon message c'est de rester responsables
les uns et les autres
je crois que ce serait une grande erreur
de penser que la 100% de la
responsabilité c'est le gouvernement et
puis ensuite nous on peut relâcher nos
comportements etc
c'est vrai que ces derniers jours moi je
vois al'approche peut-être avec quelques
bonnes perspectives de suivre qui
commençait à baisser un peu de
relâchement collectif à vous le voyez je
pense qu'on peut chaque et en faire le
constat est donc mon message c'est celui
de la responsabilité collective c'est
extrêmement important parce que on est
en train de préparer les mois qui
viennent maintenant chacun a compris que
ce virus il pouvait repartir que une
troisième vague c'est pas un tabou c'est
quelque chose qui peut nous arriver il
faut regarder ce qui se passe dans les
autres pays européens autour de nous le
virus repart et donc la situation
sanitaire elle reste fragile et je vois
que notre débat politique et se
structurent parfois de façon un peu
étonnante tous les quinze jours
à chaque fois qu'il ya une petite
éclaircie on va retrouver les uns et les
autres qui disent ah ça il faut tout
lâcher fort et ouvrir les stations de
ski etc
et puis dès que la situation redevient
un petit peu plus compliqué
tout le monde rentre chez soi on entend
un petit peu moins les uns et les autres
qui à un moment donné discothèque
ainsi ce pourquoi absolument les
stations de ski se remplissent et c'est
moi je dis la larme contre ce virus
c'est la constance et depuis le début le
gouvernement vient de constance
mais non je crois que c'est le pire
cette sorte de stop and go c'est aussi
très difficile à vivre psychologiquement
pour nos concitoyens
donc ce que le président de la
république avait fait c'était très
important de donner de la lisibilité
nous donner des critères aussi pour nous
permettre d'avancer pour venir à bout de
ce virus
on a des perspectives qui sont meilleurs
maintenant avec la perspective d'un
virus d'un virus pardon ça fait des mois
qu'on combat d'un vaccin
il faut créer de la confiance il ya un
enjeu extrêmement important autour de ça
mais en attendant en attendant la
bataille n'est pas gagnée
c'est un jeu de confiance en effet il
est il est clairement posée parce que le
sondage après sondage on s'aperçoit que
la défiance des français restent
majoritaires 1 pour ce qui concerne le
vaccin nous mêmes à la voix du nord on
avait été interrogé des soignants et
eux-mêmes pourtant largement sensibilisé
se montrait très réservé comme on peut
rétablir cette confiance c'est vrai j'ai
même retour en échangeant avec le
personnel hospitalier dans les hôpitaux
moi j'ai un hôpital dans ma
circonscription on se rend compte qu'il
ya de la défense y compris chez les
soignants
je pense qu'il ya plusieurs l'ingrédient
si on veut créer de la confiance
le premier c'est la transparence
transparence absolue sur les
caractéristiques des différents vaccins
qui vont arriver sur le rapport
bénéfice/risque il faudra tout dire et
c'est ce que le gouvernement s'est
attaché à pouvoir faire deuxièmement il
faut une stratégie qui soit lisible et
comprise par les français
c'est extrêmement important pouvoir
expliquer pourquoi est-ce qu'on vaccine
d'abord le personnel les personnes en
ehpad
puis ensuite les gens qui sont plus
vulnérables puis ensuite le reste de la
population
et puis troisièmement il faut du
dialogue et la concertation
je crois que c'est extrêmement important
et le gouvernement a fait ce choix de
pouvoir avoir du dialogue avec la
communauté scientifique du dialogue avec
les forces politiques à l'assemblée
nationale au sénat un débat la semaine
prochaine qui permettra d'avoir un débat
transparent sur cette question avec un
vote et puis du dialogue avec la société
civile
je pense que c'est une excellente idée
de pouvoir réunir des citoyens de
pouvoir réunir des associations parce
qu'il va falloir aller convaincre sur le
terrain de l'intérêt de se faire
vacciner
j'ai jamais pensé qu'on pourrait obliger
les françaises faire une piqûre dans le
bras ça n'existe pas en revanche il faut
inlassablement expliquer convaincre que
si on veut retrouver une vie plus
normale
ça passe par le vaccin c'est une
formidable chance il faut réel
ce qui est en train de se passer
l'humanité a mobilisé ce qu'elles
avaient de meilleur de recherche privé
de recherche publique c'est inouï c'est
la première fois dans l'humanité qu'on a
aussi rapidement un vaccin avec une
mobilisation sans précédent
profitons-en c'est ça aussi le
progressisme moi je porte cette savoir
regarder l'avenir avec confiance mais il
faut convaincre et c'est une question
qui est au delà du virus est un vrai
enjeu de pour notre société un mot
puisque vous parlez du débat au
parlement qui aura lieu la semaine
prochaine sur la stratégie vaccinale
emmanuel macron il s'était aussi engagé
à ce qui est des travaux au parlement
sur l' isolement des personnes
contaminées y compris des mesures
contraignantes c'est ce qu'il avait dit
vous qui présidé le parti majoritaire ça
en est où ces travaux parlement est ce
que vous allez proposer des choses
bougent peut-être que le débat la
semaine prochaine pourra donner
l'occasion d'aborder y compris ces
questions là parce qu'elles sont très
importantes avant le vaccin
l'évolution nos stratégies de tester
alerte et protégé donc tout ce qui se
passe autour des tests extrêmement
important comment on utilise des tests
antigénique comment est-ce qu'on incite
les gens à s'isoler
ce sont des questions qui sont
absolument clé pour lutter là aussi
contre le virus - je me suis prononcé
assez rapidement en étant assez réservé
sur les mesures coercitives autour de l'
isolement ce qu'ils ne sont pas aussi
sont le ce que ce que préconise le
gouvernement c'est visiblement ce
concept des groupes parlementaires de
différentes forces politiques se sont
réunis et semblait ressortir
effectivement cette idée que la voie
privilégiée
c'était plutôt celle de l'accompagnement
là aussi de l'incitation
moi je ne crois qu'une chose c'est
l'efficacité mais du coup il y aura
débat spécifique je pars je mens vous en
parlerez la semaine prochaine à
l'occasion je pense que l'occasion du
débat sur la stratégie vaccinale sera
donnée de permettre effectivement un
débat un peu plus large y compris sur
les politique d'isolement mais là aussi
la confiance
l'efficacité l'incitation je crois que
ce sont les maîtres mots
je disais
début d'entretien que les français sont
pas les enfants c'est à mon avis la
bonne méthode pour pouvoir avancer
c'est la clé dans nos démocraties il
faut créer de la confiance on voit
qu'aujourd'hui c'est peut-être le défi
principal qui est devant nous et cette
question de l' isolement belle est
symptomatique d'une certaine façon de ce
type de débat pour terminer sur ce sujet
un mot sur la commission d'enquêté
sénatoriale un qui rend ses conclusions
ce matin les sénateurs se sont procurés
un échange de mail jérôme salomon le
directeur général de la santé aurait
fait pression sur le directeur général
de santé publique france pour qu'il
modifie un rapport dans lequel il
préconise est d'acheter un milliard de
masques c'était en août 2010 8 ce que
jérôme salomon n'a pas fait résultat on
a eu un faible stock de masques en début
de l'épidémie ce que tout le monde c'est
est ce qu'il ya eu une faute est ce
qu'il ya une volonté de dissimulation
cgg découvrent en arrivant sur votre
antenne les possibles conclusions de ce
rapport si j'ai bien écouté votre invité
précédent donc je n'en sais strictement
rien je n'ai aucune des informations
dont le rapport fait mention
on verra bien ce que je sais depuis le
début c'est que le gouvernement fait de
son mieux comme tous les gouvernements
au monde pour traiter ce virus ce que je
vois c'est que nous avons réussi à faire
face deux fois à deux vac était
extrêmement importante que par deux fois
nos hôpitaux ont tenu que nous faisons
nos meilleurs efforts pour que notre
économie puisse rester debout aussi ça
je le sais sans aucun doute absolument
sans aucun doute maintenant les
conclusions de ce rapport entre verra
mais surtout que cette histoire de
masques elle elle vous empoisonne la vie
depuis longtemps il va savez j'ai dit
très tôt
que sur les masques bien on a on fait
des erreurs de communication de bonne
foi et la stratégie absolument convaincu
de bonne foi vous voyez bien ce que
disait la communauté scientifique et
compris à ce moment là et donc nous
avons aussi écouter ce que dit la
communauté scientifique qui était loin
d'être unanimes sur la question des
masses qui font quand même le rappeler
mais bien sûr on parlait de confiance
pas comment on fait des erreurs de
communication
ça joue forcément après qu d intention
de dissimuler des informations
j'en serais très étonné moi ce que je
vois depuis le premier jour où on lutte
contre ce virus c'est que le
gouvernement fait ses meilleurs efforts
on va parler de la loi séparatisme qui
ne s'appelle plus comme ça loin confère
temps qu'on porte en elle les principes
de la république parce que des principes
importants en conseil des ministres
présentés par jean castex et une partie
du gouvernement d'ailleurs dans la
foulée
est ce que pour le parti majoritaire le
plus dur n'est pas à venir avec le débat
parlementaire est ce qu'il ya des
divergences sur la laïcité au sein de
votre parent je ne crois pas et à chaque
fois qu'on a annoncé certaine façon que
notre groupe se déchiraient sur tel ou
tel débat ça n'a jamais été le cas
depuis le début du quinquennat
j'ai organisé en début de semaine un
bureau exécutif de la république en
marche qui était dédiée à ces questions
là et la ligne était extrêmement
majoritaire
nous nous sommes retrouvés sur une ligne
de dire il faut d'abord un dire les
choses clairement aujourd'hui dans ce
contexte où on veut se battre pour faire
respecter les principes républicains
il ya un an et demi aujourd'hui kir
islamisme qui est notre ennemi il faut
le dire les choses clairement qui est un
contre-projet politique qui vise à
imposer des principes soit disant
religieux sur les lois de la république
et cet ennemi là il faut être
il faut le combattre et puis il faut
avoir une stratégie globale une
stratégie globale ça veut dire être
extrêmement ferme pour pouvoir imposer
l'ordre républicain le projet de loi
contiendra beaucoup de mesures et puis
se battre pour l'égalité des chances
parce que ce projet politique islamiste
y perdure il croît sur les défaillances
de la république et donc à chaque fois
se battre pour remettre de la république
pour remettre de l'égalité des chances
pour se battre contre les
discriminations ça doit aussi faire
partie de l'autre
j'ai aucune et quand on dit cela et si
on l'a quand on dit ça la république aux
marches dans ces instances elle est
extrêmement rassemblée et donc je crois
que ce débat sera l'occasion de défendre
cette ligne politique
vraiment je suis pas très inquiet du
débat parlementaire qui vient alors il
malgré tout il ya quand même des
propositions qui vont résonner et qui
vont certainement provoquer du débat au
sein de votre groupe
on pense par exemple à la proposition
d'horreur berger d'interdire le voile
pour les pour les petites filles vous en
pensez quoi vous moi c'est pas une
proposition que je suivrai
je crois que le projet de loi que nous
avons aujourd'hui il a une grande force
c'est que n'est pas une loi de
circonstance toutes les mesures que nous
allons prendre sont des mesures qui ont
vocation à être pérenne pour renforcer
les principes républicains justement et
je ne voudrais pas qu'on ait des débats
qui nous fasse sortir de cette ligne là
j'ai vu maintes et maintes fois la
société française s'enflammer sur des
débats sur le voile se déchire et et
puis au final passer à côté des vraies
questions
je crois que ce texte de loi il va faire
les choses extrêmement importantes sur
l'éducation des petits enfants par
exemple faire en sorte que les enfants
soient attachés à l'école de la
république ça c'est très important et
donc je voudrais pas que on se perdent
dans des débats qui nous fasse sortir du
sujet principal qui est la défense des
principes le cas maintenant moi je moi
je ne serai pas favorable à cet
amendement je voterai contre si jamais
il était présenté
parce que je ne pense pas qu'il faille
se perdre dans d'autres débats que ceux
du texte de loi qui présente une ligne
extrêmement équilibrée d'ailleurs qui
fait suite au discours des mureaux du
président de la république qui avait été
bien accueillie dans la société
française parce qu'on voyait bien
c'était un discours d' équilibre à la
fois je le disais tout à l'heure sur
l'ordre républicain et sur l'égalité un
discours des clips vous faites bien de
le rappeler parce que le en effet il y
avait deux jambes aux discours des
mureaux un volet régalien volets un
volet social cela dit dans le dans le
le projet de loi on a vu ses faces et
les mesures qui avaient trait par
exemple la mixité sociale puisque on
visait à favoriser cette mixité via des
ordonnances ça disparaît du du projet de
loi ce que c'est quoi une occasion
manquée je crois pas j'espère être clair
avec vous ce matin sur le fait que nos
stratégies ça doit être stratégie
d'ensemble
les deux jambes je les assume
parfaitement et d'ailleurs je crois que
c'est ça qu'est nature justement à créer
du consensus de l'adhésion au sein de
notre famille politique
et d'ailleurs je crois au sein de la
société française qui est
majoritairement sur cette ligne là donc
il faut absolument garder ses deux
jambes après vous connaissez trop bien
la mécanique parlementaire pour savoir
que tout n'est pas législatif dans la
vie effectivement quand on examine un
projet de loi il ya un certain de
modifications qu'on va apporter à la loi
et qui ne portent pas l'intégralité des
combats qu'on doit pouvoir mener les
mesures sur le logement
je les soutiens je suis moi aussi
favorable à ce qu'on puisse prolonger
mais alors la loi sru pour que on
continue cette bataille pour la mixité
sociale je crois que c'est une part
importante du combat qu'on doit mener
contre justement les projets
séparatistes de lutter contre les
ghettos
après il faut que ça soit dans les bons
véhicules législatifs
ce sont des chantiers extrêmement
important vous savez que à chaque fois
qu'on aborde ces questions là sur sru où
toutes les questions afférentes au
logement qui vise à ce qu'on arrive à
25% en 2020 c'est extrêmement important
bien il faut le faire dans les bons
véhicule législatif pour l'instant
c'était sous forme d'ordonnancé ce n'est
peut-être pas la meilleure manière de
mener cette discussion mais je le dis
très clairement à la tête du parti
majoritaire
mais il faudrait il faudra évidemment
continuer à mener cette bataille là elle
est portée par un modèle wargon elle est
bien porté par les malins vont donc il
faudra trouver les véhicules législatifs
pour le faire et puis déployer sa
stratégie d'ensemble
là encore tout n'est pas législatif vous
savez on a fait un certain nombre de
propositions à la république en marche
lundi par exemple pour continuer à mener
la bataille contre les discriminations
notamment dans le champ économique
je crois que les entreprises ont un rôle
très important on voit bien que les
discriminations elles sont dans le
logement d'en parler
elles sont dans le monde économie quand
on a moins de chance dans un entretien à
l'embauché moi je souhaite qu'on puisse
imposer des formations tous les ans dans
les entreprises qu'on puisse faire comme
on a fait pour l'égalité femmes hommes
on a mis en place un index pour les
grandes entreprises on mesure les choses
et puis si le niveau n'est pas
satisfaisant 23 ans en entreprise pour
s'améliorer
faisons la même chose sur les
discriminations comme ça on fera reculer
ces discriminations on fera avancer ce
combat et on fera un dernier mot sur
stanislas guérini est ce que il est
vaste en ce test est ce que vous pouvez
dire ce matin tout me convient un haut
escaut nettement il ya des choses que
vous allez retravailler que vous allez
modifier non objectivement ce qui est
aujourd'hui dans le projet de loi moi ça
me convient parfaitement
le texte qui a été présenté bien sûr
cure à un travail et qui aura des
amendements on est en train de parler un
texte qui était présenté hier en conseil
des ministres et qui sera examinée fin
janvier donc le parlement par le temps
de travailler sur quels sujets
retravaillé pour moi je j'ai porté un
certain nombre de propositions lundi
avec le mouvement politique que je
représente peut-être qu'elle est chose
qui pourrait être insérée dans le texte
j'en parlais sur le champ de les
sanctions les gens déménagent fonction
vis-à-vis des discriminations qui serait
qui serait faite par par les agents du
service public par exemple
effectivement on apporter des
propositions dans ce sens là le texte va
permettre une grande avancée qui est de
mieux protéger les agents du service
public tout ce qu'ils sont dépositaires
de la force du service public et bien le
corollaire de ça c'est qu'on leur
demande
une exemplarité une responsabilité
supplémentaire et s'il y a des actes
racistes et bien il faudra les
sanctionner encore plus lourdement
voyez c'est exactement cet équilibre là
qui est de nature là aussi à établir de
la confiance entre le service public et
les usages on ferait bien parler d'eux
c'est seulement de cette meilleure
protection des agents de service public
parce que en effet c'est l'article de 25
au départ qu'il venait l'article 18
parce qu'il fallait pas trop mélanger
avec l'article 24 de la proposition de
la sécurité globale j'espère que vous m
l'article 18 qui réprime le fait de
divulguer des informations personnelles
dans un but malveillant et il permet
d'exclure de ce champ tout ce qui a
trait à la loi de 1881 sur la liberté de
la presse grosso modo ça permet d'éviter
que les journalistes se retrouvent
réprimer pour pour ce fait c'est
concrètement est-ce que ça laisse encore
une place à ce fameux article 24 si
décriée de la proposition de la
proposition doit sécurité globale est ce
qu'il faut pas lui faire un sort
définitif bas d'abord je pense qu'on a
bien fait de dire les choses rapidement
sur cet article 24 ont des papillons
mais derrière il faut savoir entendre là
aussi âpre au nom de nos erreurs parfois
par le passé on s'est répétée sur un
certain nombre de sujets nous je parle
des erreurs du passé où on a mis un peu
trop de temps à entendre et il y avait
un doute qui s'était établi dans
l'opinion sur nos intentions
on a bien fait de corriger rapidement
les choses et dire on va le réécrire
après un peu trop rapidement stanislas
grignet ce que vous n'avez pas oublié le
sénat dont non mais vous voyez un jour
sont contradictoires d'une certaine
façon auquel je fais face avec vous de
ce matin non mais je pense qu'il fallait
faire les choses rapidement pour
justement levé tous les doutes
oui nous n'avons pas été entendus dans
nos intentions sur le fait à la fois de
protéger les forces de l'ordre et de
préserver la liberté de la presse
donc on lève toutes les ambiguïtés on va
réécrire absolument dans ce sens là mais
le ces se propose déjà de le faire bien
sûr suivre mais vous avez là aussi noter
que l'examen du texte au sénat sera pas
pour tout de suite c'est plutôt pour
janvier est donc on n'allait pas laisser
perdurer un doute sur nos intentions
vous avez vu qu'il ya des manifestations
qui était samedi dernier samedi avant
aussi sur ce texte de loi est sûre cet
article précisément là aussi il fallait
lever le doute mais en fait on valoir
est écrié pour écrire ça on va leur
écrire que vous faites confiance est ce
que vous pourriez reprendre les députés
du sénat proposeront une formulation
proposeront une formulation comme ça
quand le sénat examinera le texte
les choses seront claires les sénateurs
auront sur la table
la proposition de reformulation des
députés évidemment ils pourront
travailler modifié soit prendre cette
formulation soit en proposer une autre à
c'est tout le but de la navette
parlementaire c'est comme ça qu'une
démocratie doit fonctionner je pense
qu'il faut pas qu'on donne l'impression
de découvrir ces sujets-là grand respect
pour le travail pour le sénat et grande
clarté les députés proposons dans
formulation et je le dis au passage je
pense que c'est mieux de le faire dans
le cadre de cette proposition de loi sur
la sécurité globale
c'étaient des mesures de protection des
policiers ce texte de loi et concerne
les policiers je pense que c'est bien de
circonscrire à cette question de la
protection de l'eau forces de l'ordre on
part sur d'ailleurs sur de nouvelles
discussions avec les policiers qui ont
été assez meurtri par les dernières
déclarations du président un bobo de la
sécurité est annoncé quelle est son
utilité
d'abord je tiens à dire que le président
de la république quand on écoute son
interview à brut
c'est difficile de douter du soutien
absolu qu'il apporte aux forces de
l'ordre
écouter réécouter son interview il est
absolument en soutien des forces de
l'ordre et la boue vos de la sécurité
qui a été annoncé c'est justement dans
ce sens là que ça va pouvoir mettre à
plat tous les sujets y compris les
sujets des moyens moi je tiens quand
même à rappeler que depuis le début du
quinquennat
cette majorité a voté une augmentation
des crédits sans précédent pour les
forces de l'anp c'est plus d'un milliard
d'euros supplémentaire de crédit pour
pouvoir améliorer
justement il y en a besoin le quotidien
des forces de l'ordre d'en donner plus
de moyens de permettre des recrutements
donc nous allons continuer ce beauvau il
permettra d'inscrire dans le temps cette
discussion aussi de pérenniser ses
moyens la sécurité intérieure peut-être
on verra bien le temps législatif sera
effectivement contre un il faudra faire
des choix d'ici la fin du quinquennat
mais en tout cas ça permettra
effectivement de donner une vision de
long terme sur les moyens qu'on donne à
nos forces de l'ordre pour fonctionner
elles en ont besoin
il ya eu beaucoup de rattrapage qui a
été fait depuis ces derniers quinquennat
et ça va dans le même sens c'est-à-dire
soutien absolu à nos forces de l'anp je
crois qu'il ya aucune ambiguïté dans la
majorité sur ce sujet une dernière
question sur les régionales julien alors
oui
une question tout à fait direct le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
sera-t-il votre candidat en ile de
france n'a en tous les cas il a accepté
de coordonner le travail
donc c'est notre chef de file c'est
autour de lui que les choses se font que
l'on préparons un projet que nous nous
préparons à cette élection qui va
simplement aura lieu en juin prochain
est ce que vous pourriez avoir de
candidat en ile de france et vous
rallier à un combat je sois me touré ce
que vous dites y aura un candidat
étiqueté la république en marchant le
jouet francs sur les toits porte la
majorité présidentielle pour le pays
pour la relance du pays notamment soit
représentée dans toutes les régions
après moi je ne suis jamais fermé
si les présidents de région sortants
nous disent à nous on veut bosser avec
vous faire un programme de relance
économique régional avec la majorité
présidentielle de façon claire pourquoi
pas d'après moi la porte est toujours
ouvert mais je veux que les choses se
fassent dans la carte et la majorité
présidentielle sera représentée dans
toutes les régions et ensuite on doit
avoir un dialogue avec les présidents de
région sortants mais aujourd'hui se
tendaient ni aux investitures je crois
que ça serait quand même très décalé
c'est pourquoi avec la crise c'est une
guerre qu'on connaisse ce sera dans les
prochains mois on va voir aussi les
prochains comment ça marche parce que
non mais c'est quoi ça janvier c'est
mais j'en ai là vous voyez aujourd'hui
je veux pas vous donner à calendrier vu
la situation du pays on vient de faire
le choix de décaler ces élections
justement pour retrouver des meilleures
conditions le faire en juin
c'est pas aujourd'hui qu'on va investir
des candidats où je vais vous livrer un
calendrier mais en tout cas on travaille
et en ile de france
on travaille autour jean michel blanquer
et vous reviendrez nous en parler bercy
cette année celle d'annie merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous regarde la une de
la voix du nord racisme et football une
ère s'ouvre telle c'est la question que
vous posez après le match psg istanbul
merci beaucoup à jour leur système et ça
s'est mis en face ce site au club des
territoires la mutuelle nationale
territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux
vous présente le club des territoires nj
acteurs engagés dans la transition zéro
carbone des régions vous présente le
club des territoires
[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous présente le
globe des territoires ne classe des
territoires en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale et
télévisions locales et les gens des
radios avec aujourd'hui thierry dupont
et malte il de sirop qui nous rejoignent
et romain gaspard keita
[Musique]